Hello in Korea Welcome to
the summary of simultaneous multi-component multi-component analysis using gc too drm for the symposium pls of the science science introduction in Korea In
fact, I will give you a brief announcement before the start of each.
During the presentation, there will be a 10-minute Q&A session after the
presentation. If you have any questions at any time during the presentation, please feel free to leave them in the window and we will have
7 more people answering and filming.
Hello, this
is Kang Seong-hoon, who was in charge of presenting multi-component analysis at the same time as freedom
using knowledge tutu at
2020 as ts.  I will tell you about the residual stress analysis method in crude oil, which has been implemented since March. First
, I will tell you
about the residual pesticide content analysis according to the pls system.
Unlike the most common regulatory method that presents and manages
the dv list and c span, that is, the
list of substances subject to management and the regulated concentration, it
is a comprehensive approach to management of hazardous substances, and
all items without standards are specified.  Dongdo is also a system that regulates this aro.
Here, the specific concentration is regulated behind food expenses.
However, currently, there is no solution that can perfectly cope with pls because
the appropriate analysis method according to the absence of the target substance is not yet fully equipped
.
Therefore,  It is the best way to respond with the optimal solution applicable at this point,
and this method is
an analysis using knowledge qq equipment according to Fu improvement.
Among the 413 standards and specifications of food products, where grains are
included, there are
302 10 types of multi-component analysis methods, which are
grains for management of eyebrow water in relation to production.  For
the reason that the supply and demand of expression eruption was easy, even the
problem is protected once in a penis response cycle. In fact
, in order to respond to the case with certainty, I saw that the area on the left had to be analyzed according to the law.
pns Residual Pesticide Residue The city
is preparing for member self-test analysis in relation to the ingredient analysis law
.
It is expected to apply the sp refinement process as a
patch writing method and revise it to an analysis method using a slow method that is easier than the current method
.
Then, I want to transport ps oil refinery, so
I will tell you about the analysis conditions for the 9-minute hourly rate dc voting
. Mr. Ji, who was used as a miracle, selected the Agilent Palbong part gc, and the
sms equipment was analyzed using needles and Choi 06 equipment. The
color is cute  Preparation Purchase 12 We proceeded to use the hp 5m sei column that came with it by default. In
order to secure all coffee size plans using the mass
, the analysis was conducted in a place where high sensitivity was maintained using the latter
mode at the end of the s filter mode.  I will briefly talk about the mode and move
on. The dry mode used in normal quantitative analysis of gold using ms scalpel
is a mode called multiple reaction monitoring.
And in the second code, the 2
filtered pre-cursor theories  Every piece member is generated, and
finally, the thatch energy specified in the third code is
used as quantitative and qualitative yo using a putter and two piece members.
The ion will be specified.
Here, the 210 m jet value will be used to filter in the first code.
So, in the first filter, all m jet values ​​except 210 and the
mass cafe will be filtered.
7 years filtered in that way  The value goes into the second cut and now meets nitrogen gas. By
nitrogen gas, the strategist named e110 wins
again, and the sculptor rises again. In fact, it is sculpted again from 212 circles, so
you can check these mass values ​​of 191 158.
Sculpture like that  Card n Yojoga energy goes
back to the third cut. In this third code,
all thoughts except for 550 892 are filtered.
In this way, the specified divorces are filtered so that the colored fragments are generated today and the
generated fragments are on the day.  The method of using it as a spirit because the amount is always increased is
called mrm.
Such my feet can be such a first high selectivity of all
If you analyze using 10 places,
you will be
able to find all of the n children of this time.  In this case,
because the field analyzes the additional temperature generated by sculpting the actual pumice material once more, it
is possible to analyze the total characteristics that are much higher than that of the cheek ms.
to detect
This is what can be done in the
m foot mode, since all the code toning and sculpting is done in all the codes that are guided by the food, all
the
projections can perfectly remove the other chemical lands in our baby
. Through this noise removal, the baseline through  It
has the advantage that it is possible to analyze up to low concentrations because it is possible to secure extract da extract b with high sitting night. If you
compare the data analyzed by Park Ki-seok substance 19 with mrm,
you can see it more clearly. Footnote Dongdo h 11  When the family
of 's lacked the use of the anal mode,
after succeeding in all of the words of b in 15,
it can be confirmed that smb is about 1.5 times higher.
In this mode,
you can check the amount of b of 10 times higher
The chromatogram you see is a chromatogram for residual pesticide
standard op
pv prepared
with red pepper matrix base.  You can check the neat g chromatogram of the pv concentration.
When I told you the g sheet size analysis conditions, I said that the mass mode was under
dm.  It's a way to say, but you can see it's a difference in the way the peaks are read. In
general, the mode at my end
is a method of simultaneously reading the peaks coming out of the sphere, which I call a sphere segment, in time, and at
the end of t, that is, at the end of the liner.  Em is the way to read according to the rt in the car peak
Catcher  Due to the nature of the sound before use, the cycle of cutting and using the maintenance column on the column
is getting faster. In
the case of simultaneous analysis of more than 200 types, it
takes too much time to adjust
rt after column maintenance.
This time can be reduced by automatically updating the peak rt, and
the sensitivity of the analysis component can be secured with a higher dl time compared to the general time segment method.
Let's look at the distribution of the inspection line of the data using insurer b for experience.
About 300 types  You can see that Shark's Division Seoul 7
shows a high linearity of 0.9 2 or more
. As for 7,000 devices, you can see the distribution of the loss line.
Let's check the 7010 equipment uh nod lo q value. The
value was obtained by repeating the analysis 5 times using the standard water value of cpp concentration.
You can check that the value is displayed. It is unusual, so you can also check that the
subjects are
erotic d4 ppd evil to keep veil gas
by spreading it on the selected layer.
The repetitive analysis value of each organ is also 7010, so more than 300 analysis
items are tabis drs light 10%  In
practice, as well as some of the Cloisonne items, it was found that almost all items had a per-
Sendai Stica liquor of around
10%.  I will tell you about the Nonghyup analysis method of data in crude oil. The
Ministry of Food and Drug Safety has implemented the
crude oil national residual substance inspection system in
earnest since July 2010 for the purpose of promoting public health and strengthening safety management of crude oil
.  For the past 2 years, two pilot surveys have been conducted,
and based on this, on December 16 of last year, regulations on inspections to be buried during the month were
enacted and announced.
National Residue 7
Inspection Program  The
crude oil national residue inspection program is implemented by establishing
an annual inspection plan in collaboration with the Ministry of Food and Drug Safety, Wanongjin, and the Ministry of Livestock and Food.
Inspections are performed at the
facility, and inspections of 300 won are conducted for 70 inspection items, such as pesticides. As a result of the inspection,
unsuitable raw milk is immediately discarded, and distribution is blocked, and
cause investigations are conducted on the relevant farms to prevent recurrence
.  Case management used by dairy farms Dairy houses and sanitary guidance management are
strengthened so that safe and hygienic raw milk is produced from dairy farms, and
preventive erection will be strengthened.
Pesticide residue analysis and inspection items before raw milk.
Samples 300 cases of raw milk, where the house containing the sample is the house of the chief, are
tested.
These 300 cases include farm vehicles, 200 cases for utility use
, and 100 cases that the state hates.
Inspection items for one of the latest species, such as pesticides and synthetic antibacterial agents with a risk of contamination of 6, are designated, and
in the case of a group user, only items that can be inspected within 48 hours are included as inspection items.
Inspections are conducted at 5 locations in the section of the livestock product inspection period of the local government.
Instructions for pesticide residue analysis q analysis conditions are as follows
.
In addition, using the hp 5m sui color, the
setting is set so that it can be used immediately without a separate side.  Since
all of the purchases were also from Dai Nam, the fact secured 4 1 time and
analyzed them. In the analysis
of pesticide residues in crude oil, the structure or 8 types of pesticides are included in the analyte material according to the 9 minutes of the sample
.  The pesticides that can be analyzed using Flor pd Perth Glory
Periphos Event 2
Cyphum Sick Miss Reaper Mass Ring are 5 species.
Chromatograms for each analyte
are shown on the right.
It
can be confirmed that all analyzes are neatly analyzed and separated without any problems with the cube stone. You can confirm that
each assay exhibits a high linearity of more than 0.9 ppb in the quality line between 100 ppb in the furnace
and 5 ppb standard.  You are looking at the result of repeating the analysis of the substance 6 times
.
Eh easily what format ring what sys perm s3 4
buffer 3 page is not about 1 3.5% 4 4 times 3.5%.
It was confirmed that the 5% rsd of the frames was uh 5%, and the high repetition
analysis
c was confirmed
.
It was
confirmed that the Ero table also had an error q of less than ppb
.
Now, not only the case, but now there is no semi-free crude oil, so the substances
must be analyzed within 10 ppb, so
the sword of fishery and this crude oil  You can confirm that
analysis material 2 using Smith in
g10 in pesticide residue analysis is not much of a problem
.  Pesticide analysis target uh look like
analysis now  I've done it.
Handwriting Now, it's a bit personal to analyze only these 5 substances,
so there may be restrictions like this. Because you have to
make and manage a variety of methods, you have to do a separate management.
I've analyzed it once. In
fact, you're looking at the list of analyzed compounds now.
Eh 48 Residual pesticides among livestock products. Now it's a chromatogram that proceeds with a 5-minute analysis on page 48.
You can see it as one data.
Uh, just like before pls, you can confirm that all the ingredients of the 48 pyeong actually
come out accurately without large stringy substances, and
that it is a mouth that can clearly distinguish the accrato g
.
pls in the middle of the setup file  Now, while talking
to others, I briefly spoke before one letter every month about the mind of
uh dynamic.  Now, to increase the time to build each peak and to further increase the reduction
, the analysis was conducted with a lab under the dynamic m
.
We have completed the setting to enable multi-analysis
4 out of 5 years,
we are looking at the acidity of the direct method Eom Jang-seon, that is, reducing the livestock pools is insufficient along with 48 100 pesticide residues.
You can see
that it shows a high straight line server of the above.
You can check what it represents
. Now on the right next to it  It is a chromatogram of each repeated analysis 6 times, and
you can see that almost all components come out in the size of what 5 red beans
.
You can confirm that all quantification is possible with beam's
d, and in fact, you can confirm that all components have a lod of 3
ppb.  You can confirm that
all of them satisfy the analysis results within ppb without any interference from other substances in the division of materials
.
I'll tell you about the tip.
Oh, if you use the equipment as well as the data,
there's a main where the analyte passes, and maintenance is essential.
Cutting and cleaning the combustion gas are essential. Even if you do
this maintenance well
, you can obtain high-quality data while maintaining the song password
when analyzing the current area using g10 sms.  You can think
of the
existing recovery L as the reduction and increase rate of the analyte in the treatment extraction pretreatment and concentration process.
At the time of
analysis, you need to think about the recovery rate, including the preprocessing part and the instrumental analysis part together with the aforementioned preprocessing
.
Embarrassed when Fu Visil came out  As I
said
before, it is a natural result in a way. From
the dc2 peak, a part of the Uiju liner column, etc. will occur next to the former Seoul 7.
The base of the actual calibration standard and the actual sample are different.
Some of the Inum is adsorbed to the column and the
actual sample is no longer kicked, so it
is representative by looking at the buff node compared to the actual farmer
. I will tell you while showing the actual data.
Grape
Tongue 3 This reduces the expression of the impression base.
There are no standard substances for these three, and they are the same.
There is not much change in the front part that goes in quickly because the first opportunity is fast, but now,
if you look at the peaks coming out of the rear that come out after staying in the middle part or longer, you can see a bigger difference than the actual front.
Yesterday night As I said earlier, the teenage black base Now again
, the
volume bookmark main flame
that continues the pent base.
As I said, the first room and the real concentration are
yes. The reason why it is more angular than the 4th floating method is because of this
.
It seems that it is because of the reason for the pairing
. In order to reduce this effect, cc Bethsemes is used to run, and
ap optimism below the Nonghyup analysis pick tri is also used as an analysis component protectant.
and the liner color is  If management such as on-source is also valuable
, quantitative analysis can be done a little more seriously by dedicated app analysis
using the 70s service.
If you use it, you can prevent the
first 3 rounds of the task evaluation for the 5 times mentioned above from becoming bones full
of copper swords.
You can also check
if there is any deterioration of the standard I am using because it is periodically destroyed and if there are any other problems
.  I'll tell you about priming one more time while I'm
giving it to you. If you look up the longer meaning of the dictionary of tribing, you'll find something called a child actor and a night
out.
It is said that it is a phenomenon. It is said
that
the bar takju was sieved to consolidate the ups and downs of the background surface when painting Bob Pak-
chi.  It is to use a standard blister or a real sample matrix
to do the bata chip one more time.
This framing solves the actual plagiarism problem analysis cloth
and fills the 8 areas where moisture can be adsorbed, so that the
installation team does not overestimate the cells in the analysis part.  You can prevent it, so you can do a more accurate
analysis of the end.
This priming effect and how the analysis minutes protection material
receives the echinosite and implants the active site and
evaluates it within 3 preparations
.  Actually, the Bokshin Eunwoo part here is now Raido Buyeop
Rider
Now, in a semicircle shape, most of the people see it as the personality talc part of the
7 ao at site
. Because some of the analysis water to be analyzed on the 7 ao at site is black,
a phenomenon in which the cell field application and recovery rate is high is occurring.
I'll tell you what the priming or analysis method is right. Assuming that the water quality of the public road is a standard in addition to 100 ppb on the basis of pure water,
if there is a loss of 5 in the key site such as a liner, it will be
5 90 open air detectors first.
When we say that the recovery rate is 99%,
and when it is based on a few seconds medium, when it is based on c ppv, the target chin
part is wide
.
At this time, the jet is talking about a recovery rate of 50%
. Yes, it is just a shot of the pure ome standard.
Adsorption occurred in the fertilization and host representative materials of 15 and there
is no further loss in the 3-
fold matrix because the episite is gone.
So, assuming that 9 of them arrive after the loss of the academic world, then
5 are lost based on swimming veins
, and
if you apply the 15 matrix to the 50% turn in Beomyang in the third week, how is it
actually like this?  Uh
, you'll see the 180% fashion and the representative.
So, uh, you can
easily use 3 matrix standards,
uh, 3 free, or a little high concentration standard material
first before analyzing it using something called priming.  After 3 cognitive actions
Buy the website and assuming that there is no longer a hey cap site and no neck loss in the Apieu Apieu flame,
after the age
, please analyze it using the target substance for the actual biopsies,
and then three to the mat.  Up to Separation 10, the recovery rate is 180%, what 200%, and
the concentration of sputum is evaluated higher
.  By using it like
this, you can force this loss to be maximized or darkened. The
analysis line material is here. If you put something in particular, you
can use gc to analyze the wrong area.
It is said that by interacting with the part, the time complex increase phenomenon caused by the bezel and
some governments cause the x-
telling phenomenon.  It seems to be a failure. If
you look at the job description for the actual denture crew, you can see the 5th red peak and the
3rd
peak of the godfather.
I think you can see it as a peak that is analyzed later
. Depending on the presence or absence of dentures, the peak is splitting that much
.
If you inject the jet right after doing the enemy and
do the analysis, you can attach the
neuron phenomenon. That's why it
comes out after being evaluated
for cell riba
.
At this time, flowers bloom, called 2 jet fan 1 amine  I'm looking at the mouth of my [ __ ] for pesticides.
Especially in the early days when I passed the gain control analysis report
, you can see that there are a lot of crows because it's so df telling now
.
When I took the chippy tv like this, that peep telling would appear much worse.
By using the analytical bone protectant, you can get rid of the detailing effect
and check the peaks
.
If there is no management, you cannot see a big effect.
What is the difference in the chromatogram you are seeing now?
In contrast, you can see that the pits come out much larger in the post. It is
also seen that there is no pit in the house in the data analyzed for the same gaya of the same concentration
.  It is a different look of the following cake.
Hey you, which pc line becomes 3 precure in the product, and
the angle has a very large influence on the analysis of 10.
Even if you take care of these liners, you can maintain high-sensitivity instructions without subscribing to any maintenance
. Rider  Not only that, but now you have to analyze it in the column cutting Indian art book.
To check the killing incident that needs to be putt upper press
It is time to think that the
end of the column life is over. At this time, it is not immediately replaced because the life of the column is
over.  I can
continue  You can use it right now. Now let's take a column orchestra. If I say now that upper ticks are all
, it's easy now. It's too tight. For those who haven't tried it,
what are you doing?
If you cut it, the
contaminants mentioned earlier in the book cannot be removed, so in reality it is
almost the same as before.
In the stubborn setty gathering, you have to follow it to reduce it to a size of about 1m, so that
you
miss the up-effector telling and you can see that it becomes a pearl mother with a column with efficiency similar to that of the new one.
There are no branches, since there are only a few components for analysis,
even if rt changes,
it does not take much time to set rt again and make a new 4 pour
.
Because of that, now the column is often contaminated, and if you cut frequently, it
takes too much time just to set the
rt. Now, the method you can use at this time
is 100 flush.  When it is full or
after the last peak comes out, the gas is blown backwards
so that it can not really escape now that it is buried in the column, and then
you can see it as
efficiently removing the contaminant houses.  , and the column
water level is also extended, and
contamination of the detector can be minimized because the buried materials do not enter
the detector.
over 300  It is a little more convenient and stable because it is not necessary to set the rt for this pumice material for the fourth time and
if the detector contamination is minimized, the
number of times of cleaning can be minimized for the ion source that actually needs to be cleaned once periodically.
4 And there are things like column cutting and liner replacement, but if
you use ms equipment easily, you probably clean the ion source very
regularly.
So now, set a certain period of
time and you will use the arm iron source while cleaning it every time.
And since you who clean can't use the equipment again, you made
sure to buy one ear source separately and as a spare, and while you
were holding back,  After cleaning, there are some people who use the source again by message-passing it, analyzing it,
cleaning it again, storing the Nakdong stuff again, and then replacing it like this for the next cleaning
.  It takes a little bit of time, but it also takes a little bit of time.
So
, Ellent now has a cleaning solution even if you use a strict element called Jets Clean
.  When it boils,
there is a lot of it, and now I have such a shaking on the surface.
These flowing flows purify the analysis sensitivity, so it also has an effect.
You can think of it as a solution that actually automatically cleans without 6-screening with a run cycle or a manual.
There is no actual way
to do it.  A little half a point 2 minutes 0 points 3 minutes like this  It can be cleaned automatically with a source. Since the
ear source is now cleaned using festive hydrogen gas, the actual analysis does not have
much sound.  Well, if you use these things together,
you can use high-sensitivity analysis while
minimizing contamination of the source part and minimizing periodic manual cleaning.  Content
yo yo yo Since the actual yo yo test was conducted only with real 7010 equipment, I will
now tell you the hs source used for the 7th Daily equipment as a hawk.
Also, there are many holes, and the default hole size is
shown in advance. When
this default size of 3 mm is changed to a lens with a 3-day lens arc,
the sensitivity that can be obtained while analyzing the actual residual pesticide
I tested it once to see how the line of the house and abandonment changes.
This substance you see in the detergent
is included in the corner of the multi-ingredient pesticide
.
If you look at the flow of analysis of about ppb at 1 o'clock,
you can see that the base is very dirty, the size of the peak is not very large, the pig-shaped double is touched, and the shape of the
sword is also very bad.
is a material with some limitations, so uh
, with changes due to the change of externs in the estate source here, I opened my eyes
more and tested the actual analysis to see if the analysis works well.
Third, what you see on
the left is the third place when analyzed.  And with the same conditions,
you are looking at the difference when you use 3 days to write out the difference.
Even if you simply check this once,
now, in the case of a 1mm lens, the spurs value is 25 ppv at
4600 information
outs value  This is confirmed, and when the l lens size is
changed to 3rd, you can see that the perspective comes out close to
9000. I am wrapped in the lens when the conditions are all pulled out, but even if
I change it, the sensitivity 5
response value is 1 10 times  You can confirm that there is an abnormal increase
. If you look at the smd as well as the increase in the alternative decrease, the actual
smb came out at about 3.8
on the 3rd.
You can see that smb comes out large about the
size of the plate. This increase in semi size means that the size of the mob increases, but the base
decreases a lot, so
it shows that analysis is possible up to a lower concentration.
Point 0 point 598 The
macroeconomic North Korea that came out like this also gets a little better in this way, and with
about the lateral line of the black line, it gets better with smb, and everything you do is a little bit more
efficient.
Good products have a more peak
response.
Check the actual statute. When and what 20 light skin fur color, I
wrote a
reputation.
Well, as Dad said, from 29 to 300 ppi now,
the range is wide, so you can do more books
.
Bass change
I have been using sight glasses, and the base is also compared among
the soldiers.  It's when I analyzed it. If
you look at it, the peak spirit has spread again. The Facebook tea bag underneath is getting bigger, so the
face looks more stable. It's tuna, but anyway, you've seen it before
.
And it was confirmed that other smb also came out high there. And the 2nd house double star where the 7th law line is drawn also now and the GeForce meeting up and the
society are now 25 to 3 times yes test positive to 0 video
or more will stand  9
uh ah 18:00 Not only Betty, but now
I've confirmed that the values ​​are
getting steeper in almost all the analysis items that have actually been compared.
You can see the increase, but now in the 4set, it's easy
to chew the burse earlier, 10 losses, semi-compliance,
what 5 6 batches, but when you smile and check the accounting, now the response
rule is actually what is on the left, what is on the left, etc. Gauge 3 Even when the maze was analyzed
When the cc response company freezes & changes to the 3rd place outside the bus where the parent or 5 cd is
1 20 once,
you can see that
the farmer's savage belly government has grown.
These things, such as this or color pro, are low
wages, but as the rental size changed, as you saw before, the ESEM and response
values ​​were too layered.
The time to become first peace is the same
And on the back side, now talking about a scalpel base detector n2n I
also matched this page with soccer.
Hey this
page amplifying it today I was doing a business with a more bulky softkey mound, but
when I was resting, as the size of the g lens changed,
I didn't have to give so many restaurants to enter about the liner interpretation Kiba, and the
actual rich people always came and picked it up and sold it.  It's a blessing to jump doubles as if going through a divorce in the living room.
Side and
Minji.  When you analyze it, you can see
that the unpleasant response applause comes out higher even though the wallet is lowered and the time to enter is hurt, and
the Essence immoral still feels like failure.
Even with hijacking songs,
you can easily see that this is something you hate while using ms equipment easily. If you
go for a long time easily, riders will be contaminated quickly.
If you use it, the fire page is revealed, but the increase of this ball page
is more unstoppable and a little specific
.
You can check this reexamination 3
so far seems to have explained about 8890 ghosts
4 zero rot according to release c lineup side now in-tube instruction more
knowledgeable yo youtube instruction infant that analysis about content
I will follow the words.
pn s da uh here uh uh easy agricultural production stage no gift
who else is high speed now it comes out in relation to the green horn trait.
uh min so i have the parts as , now also in person
5 how can i get tribal and get constitutional data uh and how result i will
tell you about move
yea now i see li now pro butter brave chp pve probe for evil
It's brand.
Well, it's easy. This is the now-cooled chip matrix base that has been weaned and laid
. Like the ps da ou, etc., all the ingredients now come out neatly, almost the same as the first oil
.  You can use the
statute ship speed and now between 10 and 100 pv, now 15 10
100% to create a command line
.
It's easy to work in Korea because there aren't any kids who are called bed here, so it's easy to work in Korea.
You are showing a dopetic nature of
more than 120% of the festival rest and you father that head uh spiritual need more k station linearity in
fact help almost all of them lightly now 80 to 120% so now it
shows a high work 12 and you'll see that
You can confirm that rsd within 10% at almost all speeds.
It shows my very compact size at 40% of the size of the g12
. So, now I
'm wondering if a very good choice is spreading in a lab where the lab is small and space utilization is limited.
And if you look inside, it's common.
You can check something else, but in fact, the most different thing is now here. This
is the colorless part. So, general knowledge, as I said before, use it and then
use it to reach 10m of color, or when a walkie detailing is created or achieved, a
party to sell peak it.  So you have to use
it. If you part the column, as I said, now the it of the facts will
change, and
while you are writing 5 documents, you will have to make 300 efforts like this 1 2
again as per r.
Since you are using the new light application column, you
do not need to tag with the column, you just need to set the color right away.
After such development, it is
possible to save time in the column that disappears, so it can
be done after
saving time.  I mentioned affection chess bling, but now I
will firmly study abroad and finish it
. It is possible to provide a portal layer option according to the direct payment
.  Because of that, yesterday's disliked product is
possible,
and modern times, we can provide an optimized solution for analysis.
An application note
that we made by analyzing fisherman's light 1 rice on fisher-res using
slc ssd, and an application note that is a bit optimized for use in Korea.
Both beginners and those who are like that can provide a solution with primary care coding.
And now, those who have used the Dylan Tute suit
have the same sins with
our bath equipment.
Since you use the same software called the center in your mouth,
you have been trained on the door 70 stress with that word at once when you play, and if you can use the spool,
now access lenght 5 what later etc 5
Romes various festival equipment  You can use it
and not only to provide an optimized solution to the stal bumper, but also to provide a solution that is
perfect even when almost all other lights are turned off
.  I can provide it to 2 billion people
. I want to listen to it in my free time. If you have a roof, you can ask me a question.
4 question
4 The first question is when to use priming and what material is
used,
and if priming is used, there is a difference between matrix match vs. method and long
standard even in solvent.  I will answer the question of whether it is not
there, how many times the sample can be injected after one use,
and whether additional framing injection should be done in the middle.
You asked about [ __ ].
Now that the application uses ming, you can prime it now using the sample that the train did
before you go to something before turning the standard for writing health
reasons.
If you do, the matrix arrangement method Consul Benz's vote is genuine and yes,
this is now the frame and me
.
So even if you do priming, later when you write the
sword type line, it's a little better to do it with the mattress placement inspection line, so
you can check the good false line.
I know that you usually run it. It will be
rotated once, and then it will be rotated in a run way. After you rotate it
once, you can prime again before running the next batch and proceed with the analysis. The
second question. The second question is currently  Does the equipment have an extract
lens installed with
3mm? 4mm is better than 3mm. If the value comes out, you need to ask about 5 more lenses whether it is better to analyze with 4mm
or not
.  What is there now is the Agilent
7010 equipment hs source Ace Chuck T lens. I told you about the part. The
meat shield lens is basically 3mm, and it comes in
.
Yesterday, this was 1. 5 Reasons for publishing the presentation materials  Now, pesticides have
to be analyzed in very small amounts anyway, so
there are some substances with poor thickness sensitivity,
so I'm now testing to
increase the sensitivity of those substances.  No, no.
That doesn't matter. Now, lower the sensitivity.  Depending on
whether you will see a better sensitivity or a 100-point pattern like this more
accurately,
I think you can change it to 3 days or what 312 basically comes in and proceed with the analysis.
East 2nd 3rd Li are the basics,
but the Gyubun lens is 3 days.
Hey, Street lens 3 days requires an additional purchase.
4 And the third question.
How do I solve this?
I asked a
bunch if you can't get a clean sample.
If the sample is sparked by the standard,
uh, proceed with the meteorite that is no longer available with the black line, write the name of the giant,
and proceed with the analysis.
You can always continue to watch our videos
from the link box, so it would be nice if you could use it that way.
And today, I have a lot of questions. This is the 6th question.
Oh, we didn't conduct an experiment about the catcher's room in the laboratory right now.
I don't have the results for the collection day. I
don't have a separate result
. It's planned to proceed in the future. It's scheduled for 2 o'clock. Oh,
4 manager.
My questions are all over.